the impeachment trial of President
Donald Trump starts today in the Senate
and there is no better time than now to
go through some of the really bad faith
arguments that are being made against
this entire impeachment trial so that we
can sort of get off on the right foot
and not fall for these because you are
going to be gas-lit and you are going to
be grandstand and during this process
and I want to get ahead of that if we
can so first of all there's the argument
of the things Trump did even if true are
not impeachable sometimes with the added
version of because there's no crime in
what Donald Trump did now as many of you
know if you watched yesterday's show or
if you've been around for a while you do
not need a crime to impeach the
president we have video actually of Alan
Dershowitz which has gone viral we're
back in the 1990s despite now being a
defender of Donald Trump he said you do
not need a crime to impeach a president
despite saying something very different
now here's their show it's himself we
showed this on yesterday's show it
certainly doesn't have to be a crime if
you have somebody who completely
corrupts the office of president and who
abuses trust and who poses great danger
to our Liberty you don't need a
technical crime but remember that
because the executive power is vested in
one person the president unlike the
judicial power which is vested in
justices of the Supreme Court and
inferior judges or the legislative power
in 100 senators and point and something
representatives we have one president
and to impeach a president is like a
non-violent revolution it is the most
dramatic act of undoing democracy that
is possible and that's why the framers
use the term treason bribery high crimes
and misdemeanors to suggest the English
analogy to great offenses of state we
look at their acts of state we look at
how they conduct the foreign policy we
look at whether they try to subvert the
Constitution the way iran-contra did ok
so just don't fall for it whether a
crime has been committed is not actually
at issue here it does not dictate
whether a conviction or acquittal in the
Senate impeachment trial is appropriate
if there have been crimes committed then
once Donald Trump or whatever president
is no long
in office they can conceivably be
indicted for those that's a separate
legal process that's a totally different
thing not relevant to what we are
dealing with starting today the Senate
impeachment trial of Donald Trump
now another version of this is okay you
don't need a crime to impeach but abuse
of power specifically which is one of
the two things that Donald Trump is
being impeached for is not impeachable
Trump of course two articles of
impeachment abuse of power and
obstruction of Congress and you're
starting to hear more and more abuse of
power is simply not something that's
impeachable don't be confused by that
abuse of power was one of the articles
of impeachment that was adopted by the
House Judiciary Committee against
Richard Nixon in 1974 it was adopted
against Bill Clinton in 1998 it's
nonsense
this is a talking point that will rot
your brain if you allow it to it has
already rotted the brain of many
unhinged unflinching defenders of Donald
Trump second whistleblower whistleblower
related talking points for example the
whistleblower was lying the
whistleblower committed a crime by
coming forward the whistleblower we
should know who the whistleblower is how
can you go forward without even knowing
who the original whistleblower on the
Ukraine stuff was anything suggesting
that all of the impeachment process is
invalid because of something related to
the original whistleblower don't fall
for it that's irrelevant now there have
been endless corroborations of all of
the things that the whistleblower
initially said by people whose
identities we know who were put under
oath and testified before the House
Intelligence and House Judiciary
Committee's even though there's really
no problem with the whistleblower not
being identified publicly we don't even
really need their assertions for
impeachment to make sense and I've used
this analogy before imagine that someone
anonymously calls the cops and says at
100 Main Street right now there's a
burglary in progress and the burglars
are stealing TVs and expensive works of
art the police show up
other neighbors corroborate they find
someone red-handed burglarizing does it
matter that the original call to police
was anonymous once you have witnesses
and a believed perpetrate
and evidence of the crime no it doesn't
make any difference in fact even if the
first call wrongly said they're stealing
TVs and works of art and when police
show up they say oh no you know what
they didn't actually steal any works of
art it was just TVs once the police
figure out what's going on it still
doesn't matter that the call came in
from someone who was anonymous or that
the caller got something wrong do not
fall for that talking point about
whistle blowers number three there's the
Joe Biden hunter Biden Ukraine
corruption angle okay and there's a
couple versions of that one there is
this really is about corruption in
Ukraine which Donald Trump was trying to
fix Trump shouldn't be getting impeached
for it or this really should be about
the corruption of Joe and hunter Biden
now these are two different stories
right one is Trump did nothing wrong and
his actions were justified because he
wanted to deal with Ukrainian corruption
that has been debunked circumstantially
by witnesses and remember that Donald
Trump is looking into legalizing bribery
of foreign officials as I told you
yesterday
it doesn't smash the smell test that
Donald Trump's priority here was dealing
with Ukrainian corruption the other
talking point is this really should be
about the Biden's
Joe and hunter Biden now I've said let's
look into the revolving door of
influence peddling family members of
politicians getting cushy jobs let's
look at all of that and you would have
many people in Donald Trump's family who
are guilty of that as well but it's a
separate issue it is not what
impeachment is about do not allow that
talking point to distract you this is
not about Joe Biden next there are
Republican talking points about we don't
have first-hand evidence it's all
hearsay well Republicans are trying to
block witnesses who would give
first-hand evidence of what Donald Trump
did said and wanted to do they can't be
allowed to invoke that talking point
while simultaneously blocking witnesses
as I told you earlier the White House is
going crazy trying to prevent les
harness from testifying in the Senate
impeachment trial the White House is
considering classifying former national
security adviser John Bolton's testimony
to prevent that from being public and
yet they say it's all hearsay we
have firsthand witnesses first of all
hearsay is a valid form of evidence in
such a trial secondly it's not all
hearsay we had plenty of first-hand
evidence in the house hearings and third
we'd have a whole hell of a lot more of
that first-hand evidence if they stopped
trying to block witnesses so will we get
a fair trial no will senators be
unbiased arbiters of this trial no of
course they will not but at least don't
fall for the bogus talking points these
four or five talking points that they
are trotting out and repeating ad
nauseam because they are just that they
are bogus talking points that should
make you nauseous the fact that so many
of these talking points work is in part
because so much of the country either is
busy living their lives where they hear
it and they don't really have the time
or wherewithal the resources to go and
investigate it and I sympathize with
that or because they've been
successfully primed by Donald Trump with
talking points like fake news and all of
this stuff to simply disbelieve anything
that sounds like maybe Donald Trump did
the wrong thing maybe the White House's
intentions are not fully on the
up-and-up all I can do is tell you what
the talking points are and why they
don't make sense let's all now be armed
with them as the Senate impeachment
trial gets going
so you're someone who enjoys thinking
about politics you love learning about
countless other topics but you just
don't have enough time in your week to
read or listen to all the books you've
been meaning to get to blink astiz an
app that will completely transform the
way that you absorb information and
ideas because what they do is take
thousands of non-fiction books extract
the most important insights and
information and then present each book
to you as text or audio which you can
consume in just 15 minutes
imagine how well-rounded you will become
once you have the ability to read five
books in one sitting or listen to a new
book on your commute every day obviously
we should read the full versions of
books whenever we can it's what I try to
do but it is a reality that there's a
whole world of books out there that you
will never get to but blinka swill help
you get to more i've just finished
listening to upheaval by Jared Diamond
Jared Diamond a tremendous author whose
work I've previously recommended
excellent book looking at some of modern
history
biggest national crises to figure out
how different countries ended up in such
precarious situations you'll be able to
have conversations with people about
totally new topics you can feed your
curiosity in ways that you've never been
able to before and the best part is it's
only about eight bucks a month which
gives you unlimited access to every
single book in their catalogue they have
books on politics economics philosophy
science you name it you can try it out
yourself totally free for a week and get
25% off if you decide to subscribe just
by going to blink is comm slash Pakman
I've put the link right underneath this
video like the rest of us I bet you're
going into 2020 thinking about what you
didn't get around to in 2019 and your
goals for the new year if you want to
work towards being your best self
in 2020 understand more about the world
around you and make sure that your time
is well spent
then blink astiz for you